all right let's talk just kind of macro
environment and kind of monetary policy
uh you said that the inflation rate is
eight percent the fed says that it's
five point four percent i tend to think
you're closer explain why you think it's
eight and they think it's five
well i mean the transitory number was
eight you know let's give them whatever
they want you want to say it's five
that's a ridiculous number that means
you're in negative rate territory in the
united states that means you're in my uh
intellectual mentor paul tudor jones is
reporting this morning what you and i
both know the obituary for the 60 40
portfolio has already been written and
now the question is what are we going to
do where are we going to go
and you discovered before i did that
there are digital hard assets
that are going to replace fiat assets
because unfortunately like nakamoto said
11 or 12 years ago
we corrupt those assets and so
you caught me in this room on your
earlier versions of your podcast where
we were talking about the history of
money i wasn't yet in bitcoin but i was
indicating to you why i was moving that
way
because we've now jumped the shark
to use a happy days expression on money
if you've made
and you know these numbers pom because i
follow you on twitter you know you tell
me what's the m2 up 40 40 40 percent
yeah for
yeah let's just call it 40 for the sake
of this argument okay uh what what what
amount of money's been printed well if
you look through the beige book
uh it was 592 billion dollars at the end
of may
i can only guess because i haven't seen
the recent number but i'm going to say
it's close to
i don't know 650 billion dollars has
been printed by the federal reserve this
year
uh so that's going to show up in the
inflation data that
that's killing
the people
in our family
that didn't get educated or don't own
bitcoin you know i'm from a family of
immigrants as you know italian
immigrants my dad was a crane operator
a lot of my
contemporaries my cousins are
clamming in oyster bay they're cutting
deli meat they're installing auto glass
they can't catch up with this nonsense
you and i can own assets our assets are
going to appreciate and our standard of
living will be just fine but if you're a
wage holder and the federal reserve is
printing 700 billion dollars of money
you're screwed pom and i and i told you
that when we first met when they broke
the contract with gold in 1971
they slowly eroded middle and lower
middle class living standards and now
we're living in an age of populism
economic desperation for a large group
of people which used to be economic
aspiration
and we've weakened the society so when
you see something like bitcoin you're
like oh my god this is a technological
innovation
which can actually be a store of value
for those people can help the
underbanked
and could literally transform the world
and if we get this thing right and it
exponentially networks to the billion
plus users that you and i both think
we'll get to
well then hold on it's going to check
it's going to hand check the bankers the
central bankers they're going to be
forced into a box
of fiscal responsibility and conformity
because if they don't do that there's
another option for human beings
aka bitcoin or you pick one of the other
cryptocurrencies that you like but you
get you get the point that i'm making
for sure and one of the things i don't
think people really appreciate well
there's two points with you right so one
is you're a student of history i
remember when we did the podcast you
laid out the history of money better
than anyone i walked out of there and i
said i don't know how that guy remembers
all that information but he's like an
encyclopedia the second thing is that
when you decided to actually enter the
market i believe you guys bought 400
million dollars of bitcoin was kind of
the first foray
you have a very very good memory yeah is
that correct
yes that is correct and so uh we are
sitting on a little over a billion
dollars of bitcoin
um to your brother's comment uh we've
had to sell some because
in our fund now i have a core bitcoin
fund the first trust skybridge bitcoin
fund that's a total huddling situation
i've got a lot of money in that
personally but in our flagship fund sort
of the nine billion dollars that we're
running
um we started with 400
uh would have loved to have left it but
i can't be in a situation in the
flagship fund where bitcoin is eating up
the whole fund so
i i i took some out of there we sold
some uh uh but we're going to leave it
for right now it may trade back to 50
000. i don't know
what i do know though
is it's likely to get to 150 000 over
the next 12 months i'm going to stick
with my uh earlier price target that i
shared with you on our salt talk when
you did my podcast i think it's a
hundred thousand by year end
um and i just think it's that because
there's now
a gateway opened guys you know this
anthony a gateway opened yesterday
where an institution can now say i can
buy this
um you know if you're a vaxxer or an
anti-vaxxer some of my friends said well
i'm not getting vaccinated until the fda
approves the vaccine
and so that sort of metaphorically
happened for bitcoin you got an approval
from the sec bitcoin lives
in the financial regulatory ecosystem
and it's not going anywhere and now that
portal has opened for
a sophisticated early adopting
institution to say it's okay for me to
step in the water here i'm not going to
get fired if i own this thing so